just how triggering are our phones when
it comes to dopamine okay great question
we often hear that
you know the social media getting
dopamine hit after dopamine hit
when we first get on social media after
a walk for the first time or after a
long period of time the amount of
dopamine that's released we think is
quite substantial it's novel remember
dopamine is about novelty surprise and
the sense that we are on some exciting
track that's what dopamine is really
about it puts us into states of
readiness anticipation looking seeking
etc almost always for things outside the
confines of our skin
just to contrast it maybe for a bit more
of a future discussion
serotonin does the opposite when there's
a lot of serotonin in our brain and body
typically it makes us feel satisfied
stated more quiescent comfortable with
what we have in our own immediate sphere
and within us right the comfort of a
good meal the food you have dopamine is
about go go go if you look at somebody
who's high on cocaine or methamphetamine
it's all about pursuit because that's a
very dopaminergic drug you look at
somebody who's taken a drug
and i'm not suggesting people do this
but it really ramps up serotonin let's
say a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor prozag zoloft etc
the side effects of those drugs if the
dosages are too high lack of appetite
lack of libido
kind of meh about life you know then so
they'll adjust the dose down that's
because those are serotonergic drugs
so
in in general
we are in pursuit of things dopamine is
is quite high so
now you have to remind me your question
because i've set up the dopamine
serotonin
cell phones yes
um forgive me so
the thing about cell phones is when you
first get on there
and you haven't let's say you're no
wi-fi on the flight or something and you
land it can actually be quite
stimulating you get a lot of dope i mean
oh there's this oh there's that but very
quickly when you're scrolling on social
media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
behavior where that we can define an
obsessive-compulsive behavior where the
obsession leads to a compulsion so the
obsession is a thought the compulsion is
a behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession
right this is very different than being
obsessed with food or obsessed with
cleanliness there's no payoff right
exactly there's no anxiety relief by
carrying out the compulsion with ocd
behaviors
like scrolling social media the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're just sort of and we've all been
there you're scrolling like why am i
doing this this isn't that interesting
that is this isn't that interesting now
the algorithms for social media are very
clever and i don't want to demonize it i
you know provide a lot of a lot of my
life is spent on you know on social
media now but
in the algorithms that they've
incorporated function on the the most
powerful
way to keep people doing a behavior or
an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something typically it's
very high what you know in nerd speak
we'd say signal to noise so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news this came out and
then it's all of a sudden a riot
or a person that is jumped base jumping
off a building or um you know for people
that are are scrolling looking at bodies
or something like that live bodies so
hopefully people aren't looking at the
dead bodies but look if something's very
tragic then that has this gravitational
pull and then you what happens is you
start getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling so i look at social media as
initially being very dopaminergic
driving reward surprise and excitement
but very quickly transitioning to
something more like ocd
and the kinds of behaviors where it
looks if you if we were to look at
ourselves through the lens of an
experiment like we would an animal
experiment we think that animal is sick
if you saw an animal digging in the
corner looking looking looking looking
for a bone the dog is looking looking
looking looking looking looking looking
looking you'd think that's really sad
that's us what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you